Hey Thoughty2 here.
According to YouTube's analytics roughly 80%
of people watching this video are under 35
years old.
Marketers have invented a name for this demographic
of impressionable young people, they're called
"Millennials", others have labelled them "Generation
Y".
A millennial is anyone born after 1980.
That includes myself and most of my viewers.
In fact Millennials now outnumber every other
generation.
But according to multiple studies we are the
most depressed generation, ever.
Psychology Today reports that the suicide
rate amongst young adults has tripled since
the 1950s and terrifyingly suicide is now
the second most common cause of death amongst
college students.
Between 2005 and 2014 the number of clinically
depressed teenagers increased by more than
half a million, three quarter's of whom were
women.
Every year more and more millennials are taking
time off work and are seeking help for mental
health issues.
An even greater number report extremely low
job satisfaction and say they experience difficulty
maintaining relationships.
Young people get a lot of stick, the older
generation have always experienced "juvenoia",
a fear or hostility directed at the younger
generation.
This is nothing new.
Baby boomers, born just after the war, had
a strong work ethic and believed that the
amount of hours worked should be directly
relational to their income.
Baby boomers heavily begrudged the generation
that came after them, generation X.
They were more independent, they changed their
careers more often and believed in a fair
work/life balance.
And now it has come full circle once again,
Baby Boomers and Generation X-ers alike are
resenting Generation Y, the millennials.
Who have brand new values, such as collaboration,
work that's actually meaningful and impactful,
having fun in the workplace and of course
free food.
Do previous generations look down upon us
just because we're different or is it more
than that?
Even TIME magazine has poked the millennial
beast, calling them "Lazy, entitled narcissists
who still live with their parents."
Ouch!
But unfortunately, they could have a point.
Unlike the generational divides of last century,
there is a lot of research and statistics
that suggest every bad label millennials have
been tarred with, may be well-deserved, even
if it isn't through our own fault.
The cold hard facts don't lie.
The volume of incidents of narcissistic personality
disorder is three times higher for people
currently in their 20s, than the average.
Are we really all in love with ourselves because
we received 50 likes on our latest selfie?
Experts believe there are very real, observable
causes of this heightened narcissism.
Millennials are the first generation that
were brought up on reality television, and
every year more and more superficial faux-reality
programming is shoved down our throats.
They advertise narcissism above all else,
portraying looks and popularity as the source
of fame and happiness.
In such shows, real human relationships are
often shown as being cheap and disposable.
And then of course there's the social-media
swamp that drowns us in a sea of likes, shares,
pins and follows.
Countless studies have shown that dopamine,
the pleasure chemical is released in the brain
when we receive likes on our photos and videos.
This system breeds narcissism at its very
core.
It appears the more narcissistic we are and
the more selfies we upload, the more likes
we will inevitably receive and sadly, this
actually makes up happier.
Experts also accuse us of being entitled.
A recent study revealed that 40% of millennials
believe they should be promoted every two
years, even if they haven't earnt it.
Research shows that this entitlement to be
given handouts, regardless of one's performance,
stems from an unusual place.
Remember school sports day?
Even if you came in last place, you still
got a trophy, just for participating.
But even if you didn't as children we were
always rewarded for taking part somehow, "It's
the taking part that counts", remember.
Countless studies have proven that this attitude
creates a disingenuous and diluted sense of
achievement and can be deeply damaging to
our future expectations of what it really
takes to achieve something.
This philosophy is unique to our generation,
Generation X-ers, Baby Boomers and those before
them were all brought up in a deeply competitive
environment.
It was instilled within them from a young
age that rewards have to be earned through
hard work and graft.
They were not told that they were entitled
to anything.
The so-called silent generation that lived
through both World wars certainly didn't feel
entitled.
They lived through the hardest period of modern
history and everything they had earned they
had to cling onto with their lives.
This meant that when they brought up their
children, the Baby Boomers, they instilled
them with a strict mentality of saving every
penny and an extremely hard work ethic.
They were told that nothing in life was free
or even expected.
It was all up to them.
The baby boomers grew up and had children
of their own, Generation X and thus they passed
on the same hard work ethic.
But then a huge shift happened in the global
economy that changed everything.
Generation X lived through a time of great
prosperity, industry was on the rise and the
world was finally dragging itself out of the
pit it dug for itself during the war.
This gave gen-Xers a "can do" attitude.
And so they taught their children, us millennials,
that if you put your mind to it you can do
anything, become anyone and live a very successful,
happy life.
You are special.
This has created a generation of people who
all believe they are special, why wouldn't
they?
Their parents have drilled it into their heads
that they are special and unique.
Millennials are completely fame-obsessed too,
four times as many teenagers would choose
to be the assistant of a famous person rather
than the CEO of a major corporation.
In a recent poll, when asked what they would
like to do for a career 54% of 16-year-olds
answered "Become a celebrity".
Far gone are the days when becoming a celebrity
was just a side-effect of demonstrating a
unique talent to the masses.
Millennials are also lazier, we have grown
up with technology that can think for us.
And therein lies the biggest problem that's
ruining the lives of young people today.
Mobile phones.
I know, you've heard it a hundred times, mobiles
are bad for you.
But do you really know why, and just how damaging
they are for our mental health?
Because the research is terrifying.
So you're out enjoying a meal at a restaurant
with family or friends.
How many times do you check your phone over
the course of that meal?
The average millennial checks their phone
over 100 times per day and they touch, tap
or swipe on their phone over 3,000 times per
day.
Why?
Because we're all addicts.
I mentioned earlier that receiving likes releases
dopamine, well so does hundreds of other things
we do with our phones.
Taking a picture of your food, taking a selfie,
writing a status update that you just cooked
the most amazing omelette of your life.
All of these acts release dopamine, even before
we upload them to the internet.
Dopamine is released in advance because our
brains anticipate the multitude of likes and
shares it should hopefully receive.
Within seconds we start receiving feedback,
this is instant gratification, instant approval
from our peers.
And it goes on and on, round the clock, we
receive instant gratification when we wake
up, peer approval before we go to bed and
through the middle of the night.
The dopamine swirls and swirls in our brain
in an ever-lasting continuum of self-fulfilment
and reward.
This only serves to perpetuate our narcissism.
Until it stops.
When we upload a photo of our chia seed and
avocado toast and it doesn't receive as much
attention as we'd hoped.
In our minds our peers have rejected us.
We are now lost, without purpose, we are now
depressed.
Does all this sound familiar?
This cycle of massive releases of dopamine
followed by periods of intense sadness?
Sounds very much like an alcohol or gambling
addiction doesn't it?
Wether we like it or not have become a generation
of addicts.
We check our phone at dinner because we're
addicted, it's the reason we put in on the
table next to our food.
Putting the people we should be spending quality
face-to-face time with, in second priority
to our little dopamine device.
It's the reason we don't talk to people on
the bus, on the train, at school or work,
we instead indulge wholly in our addiction
whenever we can.
Because we are truly addicted, and most of
us don't even realise it.
A survey of more than 2,000 millennials found
that 93% use their phones in bed and 80% use
their phones on the toilet.
But it's not your fault.
Millennials are simply a product of the environment.
This is the hand we were dealt.
We grew up in a time of rapid technological
advancement.
As long as mobile devices continue to generate
enormous profits, then companies will continue
to develop new digital mechanisms and social
networks that provide instant gratification.
And it keeps coming quicker and quicker, we
no longer have to wait for our next fix.
It's instantaneous.
We have Snapchat, Facebook, Instagram, Twitter,
Pinterest, WhatsApp any one of which can provide
our next fix whenever we desire it.
And if not we can simply connect some digital
candies to make us feel better.
Our parents didn't have these distractions,
they had to put time and effort into receiving
the approval of their peers.
They had to have meaningful conversations
and form strong, deep, and long-lasting relationships
with both their friends and partners to get
their dopamine fix.
At work they had to graft day after day and
when that promotion came along, my god had
they earned it.
In contrast millennials have become immensely
impatient, we are so use to instant gratification
that if we don't get a promotion ten minutes
after we start a new job, we get bored of
it, because it isn't the sort of timeline
we are use to.
We say we want to make an impact yet we expect
to do so within our first 6 months at a new
job.
And when 6 months or a year has gone by and
we're still the tea and coffee guy for the
office it makes us feel disenfranchised, worthless
and depressed.
But it's not your fault, you have grown up
in a maelstrom of dopamine on tap whenever
you desire it.
So naturally you expect the same instant fulfilment
from your career and relationships.
But we can't tap a button to help us achieve
that, there is no virtual replacement for
hard work and genuine conversations.
We can't swipe right to get promoted and I'm
sorry folks but it's going to take more than
commenting on your partner's latest selfie
to make them feel genuinely valued and loved.
Take them on a date for goodness sake and
don't look at your phone the entire time,
because the moment you do, they are now second
priority.
So should we be worried about the future,
of a World run by these oh-so-terrible millennials?
Are millennials really so ill-prepared to
fill the boots of the previous generation
in 10-20 year's time?
These narcissistic, self-obsessed, lazy, entitled
young adults who want success given to them
on a plate, who can't tie down a relationship
or achieve satisfaction in the workplace because
they're too addicted to social media.
Well, I wouldn't be so worried.
Yes, we young people have our issues but we're
actually no different to the last generation,
Generation X were also labelled as entitled
and lazy when they were young.
As a society we need to recognise that the
World has completely changed, both technologically
and culturally over the past twenty years.
And millennials are the first adopters of
this strange new lifestyle, where you can
build a billion-dollar business from your
bedroom, if you put your mind to it.
All our apparent faults are merely symptoms
of trying to adapt to a completely strange,
new way of life that our parents didn't have
to deal with.
We face new and unique pressures, stresses
and challenges and we need to find better
ways to cope with them rather indulging in
social media.
And for all our faults there are actually
a lot of good things to say about millennials,
that are rarely brought up.
Millennials are the most tolerant generation
ever.
Research shows that prejudice has fallen with
each new generation.
Millennials are far less racist, homophobic
and sexist than their parents.
Pew research asked adults aged between 18-29
what their most important priority was during
their lifetime.
52% answered "Being a good parent".
30% said "Have a successful marriage".
21% replied "Helping others in need".
Now that doesn't sound like a generation that
is completely self-absorbed now, does it?
And our inability to settle into a normal
9-5 job may not be entirely due to our reliance
on social media.
Maybe it's because we all want more than the
monotonous normality of working for some heartless
corporate giant.
Research shows that millennials are the most
entrepreneurial generation ever.
Spurred on by young do-it-yourself success
stories like Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg.
As a generation we have an unstoppable appetite
to achieve something big and make an impact.
Right after we've finished sending this hilarious
Snapchat.
This mentality might be proving difficult
for large corporations who need to employ
cheap young labor that can sit in an office
and push buttons for eight hours a day.
But it's changing the world in ways our parents
could have never imagined.
There's no doubt we need to spend more time
interacting with one another and less time
on social media, all the research has shown
that it does bad things for our mental health.
But we need to accept that the world is rapidly
changing.
Millennials have their faults but they are
also contributing to the world in so many
incredible ways.
Just like the generation before us, and the
generation before them.
Change has always come and always will, Its
inevitable, so we need to find a way to work
with it for the better instead of spending
our time pointing out the faults in others.
Thanks for watching.